Is it the gluten we're staying away from in wheat?
Naturally, or is it the glutamate that is sprayed on wheat? That's bad
We have access to organic wheat berry milled flour
so no, so
Some people have said and you've probably seen it out there that
Gluten sensitivity is nonsense. It's really the glyphosate that's sprayed on wheat that people are reacting to
While I agree that there's a probably a lot of people that are reacting to the glyphosate sprayed on wheat
Therefore we should be before buying wheat. We should be buying organic wheat berries and
organic flour
So we should be buying organic everything if possible
because
You know, especially grains are going to be sprayed with glyphosate. It's not glutamate
I think you're talking about glyphosate. So that's round up again
So yes, we should be buying those things organic
but if I
As if I had listed in your cancer
Cheekswab test that you have to stay away from gluten. It is nothing to do with the glyphosate
It's that gluten is the driver. So why would gluten be a driver? Well gluten
I
Technically isn't a quote unquote driver, but it's what gluten does to you that causes the cancer to grow
because if a person has a gluten issue it could cause every time you eat it it's going to cause inflammation
both in your brain and in your gut
so
gluten and
dairy
have more feed receptors in the brain
So you have what are called gluteal morphine and caseal morphine receptors that go right to the brain and are going to cause inflammation of the grain in the brain
So if you have k-seed sensitivity or
gluten sensitivity, you're going to cause brain inflammation and you're going to cause intestinal inflammation
You're going to cause bodily inflammation and now you're going to make person with cancer
at to fight this immune reaction at multiple ends and the army is going to have a better chance of losing the battle
So when I tell you in your Cheekswab test and in your binder to stay away from dairy
There's multiple reasons why you're staying away from dairy. Dairy can be a driver
Dairy can be a source of inflammation and mucus production. Dairy can increase
different
growth pathways
Gluten is going to if I tell you to stay away from gluten. It's mainly because of inflammatory pathways
and then
gluten is
highly inflammatory to the brain and it's a
molecular mimic to different
antibody
production. So if a person has thyroid issues
even if they just have
Rivalry hypothyroidism, they shouldn't be eating gluten because gluten is a molecular mimic to the thyroid
So the chance of you
moving from
Rivalry hypothyroidism to Hashimoto's is pretty high if you're continuing to eat gluten if you have
if you have
primary hypothyroidism, so understand primary hypothyroidism you have to a low functioning thyroid, but you don't have antibodies to the thyroid yet
Hashimoto's is now you have antibodies to the thyroid
Likewise, when you have neurological antibodies, you have antibodies to neurological tissue like myelin sheath
antibodies and
some other antibodies to different neurological tissue
It's a cross-reacted to that antibody. So gliadin and gliadin peptides
can be a cross-reacted to that
neurological antibody. So every time you eat gluten, you're causing more inflammation in the brain and direct
destruction of
the
neurological structures that which you have antibodies against. So if you have myelin sheath antibodies and you continue to eat gluten
you're gonna you're gonna end up with the you know more of a demyelinated disease. You're gonna end up with progression of
your
multiple sclerosis
and you're gonna end up with a further degeneration of the brain. So
gluten could be a bad player in that arena.
Is gluten ever a direct fuel source and by itself to the cancer? No, it's an indirect
driver, I would say, or indirect influence of cancer because of the inflammatory process.
Well, but what if I buy organic wheat? Is that gonna cause the same problem? Yes
because organic wheat is still has the protein called gliadin in it whether it's
you know
Lated with glyphosate or not is different. So it is meaningless. So it's still a problem. So even if it's
great
Organic source wheat now some people have said well, you know, I react to gluten, but I don't react to
Gluten from wheat from France or Italy. Well, the reason is is because that is an older form of grain that
encases the gliadin tighter. It doesn't liberate as much gliadin.
However, if a person has antibodies to
the thyroid and or primary hypothyroidism or antibodies to neural tissue it still doesn't make any difference
You still can't eat that
But if a person doesn't have any of those antibodies has no thyroid issues and just does show gluten sensitivity
Still if they show antibodies in the Syrex 3x test, you still can't eat
In these ancient grains you still can't
However, let's say you do a Syrex 3x you don't have any antibodies, but you know gluten isn't really good for us
So you've been staying away from gluten. You do not have any neurological brain antibodies, nor do you have any issues with your thyroid could you eat
some ancient wheat or could you eat some
Wheat that is from Europe France and Italy that has that is basically more the ancient grains
Probably yes, you probably could too much of any of that could spark a gluten sensitivity so you have to be careful with that
But yeah, you'd probably be okay in that case, but that's really not the cases we're talking about